[Applause]
[Music]
that wasn't very nice it is arguable
that creator charlie brooker's episodic
anthology series black mirror is one of
the scariest shows on tv not because it
relies on zombie attacks or murderous
clowns but because it shows just how
easily phones computers and other
advancing technologies that we are
increasingly dependent on can be used
against us if we're not paying close
enough attention
[Music]
now the fact that all of these episodes
are available to be played on netflix
the innovative streaming giant known for
obsessively monitoring our usage without
really sharing what they find should not
be overlooked lol and rotten tomatoes
has crunched the numbers to rank the
best black mirror episodes don't you
dare no we can talk tomorrow just please
stop
cut it off
we've updated the list to reflect the
current tomato meter score however it's
worth noting that early episodes have
scores of a hundred percent on fewer
than 20 reviews while most recent
episodes may not have perfect scores but
they have more reviews in case of ties
those titles with more reviews ranked
higher with the average rating taken
into account where episodes had the same
score and number of reviews now with all
of that out of the way this is your
spoiler warning for pretty much all of
black mirror because we're counting down
the best black mirror episodes ever
[Music]
starting with number 10 season 2 white
bear similar to the twist at the end of
white christmas this season 2 episode
explores the way technology can be used
to enforce punishment it stars lenora
krishlo as a woman who wakes up with
amnesia in a strange home where tv
screens blast an unknown image and she
finds a picture of herself with a man
she doesn't recognize and of a small
girl but this is not a sympathetic story
of a family's attempt to reunite instead
we learned that chrysler's character is
named victoria and she was an enabler in
an act so terrible that she has been
sentenced to relive her own kind of
torture every day for the amusement of
strangers who hate her starring lenora
chrysler michael smiley to pence
middleton and directed by carl tibbetts
critics say white bear makes up for its
blunt social criticism with its intense
scare factor and final twist
[Music]
[Music]
come on
come back
[Music]
number nine season one the entire
history of you
several black mirrors episodes deal with
technology's role in for better or worse
aiding romantic relationships now this
episode offers a dark turn on something
so many of us have seen before the
obsessive need to learn about your
paramour's past relationships to the
point where you no longer trust that
person causing the relationship to
self-destruct toby kebbel stars as a guy
so obsessed with seeing imperfections
that he has a device planted behind his
ear that lets him redo various moments
of his life naturally this backfires
when he sees his girlfriend chatting up
her ex at a party also a fun bit of
trivia this is the only episode to date
that does not carry brooker's byline in
some capacity it was actually written by
succession creator jesse armstrong
starring toby kebble jody whitaker tom
cullen and directed by brian welsh
critics say examining how technology
amplifies human characteristics the
emotional punch of the entire history of
you comes from positing that we don't
need futuristic technology to ruin a
relationship we can do it all by
ourselves no i'm a serial monogamist
i'm staying faithful to my conflicts
right now
um
no no i don't know you do
morning
what's this i'm just getting gina's
opinion on something
no i'm a serial monogamous time
i'm staying faithful to my conflicts
right now
i was just wondering because
you found it funny but it clearly isn't
and gina agrees i don't really want to
get involved yeah let me get you a cab
my dad's on it just want just one one
other thing
we both want him to come back
but
who wants him to come back more in your
opinion off the top of your head who
wants him to come back more
okay well bye
yeah bye
wow it's early it's early to call it a
night
fancy equipment down the pub oh you
gotta get back rescue jody from the
pedophile babysitter
that's just that's a joke yeah
number eight 2014 christmas special
white christmas
a perfect holiday special for anyone
needing a break from being locked in the
house with their relatives this episode
also explores themes seen in the second
season episode white bear rave spall and
jon hamm stars two guys stuck in a cabin
for past transgressions but whose crime
is worse who stands to benefit when the
other spills and how long have they been
in this cabin again starring jon hamm
rafe spall oona chaplin and directed by
carl tibbetts critics say this yuletide
nightmare gifts black mirror fans with a
bleak mind twister of an episode and a
stocking stuffer of existential dread
sorry
who are you
stall until i until i find something
pretty sure i'm me
just you're not from the office
who do you know from here
say i know you
friendly
i know you for one
dawson
dawson isn't it
you met at cath's barbecue
yeah we met at cass bbq back in
june or so yeah
you're a pork pie hat you had a poor
guy's hat
a pork pie hat
a pork pie hat that you that you wore on
your head
he'll pretend he remembers even though
he won't actually know if he does
right
yeah
yeah number seven season two be right
back
one of a handful of black mirror
episodes to discuss technology's role in
alleviating loss this episode stars
haley atwell as martha a young woman who
uses ai tools as a coping mechanism for
getting over a boyfriend who perished in
a car accident now because your tweets
don't die just because you do she
utilizes his social media interactions
to recreate him in android form it does
not go well for martha but it does posit
the question of whether the bereaved can
ever have closure if we still see our
beloved's images and data in our phones
or receive annual bombardments of their
birthdays on facebook starring haley
atwell domino gleason claire keyland and
directed by owen harris critics say be
right back tones down black mirror's
typically dark humor but its examination
of grief in the age of social media
makes it an exceptionally powerful
episode
so you do want me to go just get out get
out
get up get out get out get out you're
not enough of him you are nothing you're
nothing
fight me i don't do that
fight me hit me
hit me
hit me come on why are you just standing
there taking this how can you take this
did i ever hit you
no
no of course you didn't you might have
done if i'd done this oh this
i don't know maybe you would have but
you wouldn't would you you would
i could insult you
what
there's tons of invective in the archive
i like speaking my mind i can throw some
of that at you
get out of his house
number six season three san junipero
a stunning work of production costume
design and music supervision as it is
storytelling this third season episode
follows the building romance between
gugu and bathurst kelly and mackenzie
davis's yorkie through several
decade-specific fashions and nightclubs
along the way we get lessons on
everything from aging to the jeopardized
rights of both members of the lgbtq
community and persons with disabilities
it also makes us wonder if there's a
chance that someone who had a pretty
crummy life has a chance at finding love
and peace after it's over or as singer
belinda carlisle reminds us at the end
is heaven a place on earth starring gugu
in bothara mackenzie davis denise burst
and directed by owen harris critics say
black mirror delivers an
uncharacteristically uplifting and
enjoyable ending in san junipero an
especially bright and sweetly surprising
episode that benefits greatly from its
vibrant lead performances i'm sorry
i'm not gonna jump i know i'm i'm sorry
whatever it's
in the time i've been here i said i
wouldn't
i don't know
do
feelings
you freaked me out
i don't want to like anyone
so you've been just
totally freaking convenient
is that
i don't know how long there is
and i can't i
i wasn't prepared for you for wanting
something
[Music]
number five season four hang the dj
just when you think online dating
couldn't get any more awkward and
uncomfortable there's this season four
episode set in a world where an
algorithm will handle the messy work of
finding uma and enforce exactly how long
you have to cohabitate with that person
it stars broadchurch's georgina campbell
and peaky blinders as joe cole as
star-crossed lovers who must learn to
listen to their hearts instead of the
programmers commands now it's also one
of the few black mirror episodes that
comes with a truly happy ending as the
couple make like butch and sundance to
buck the system and stay together
starring georgina campbell joe cole
george blagdon and directed by tim van
patten critics say surprisingly sweet
and satisfyingly slight hang the dj adds
a welcome dose of optimism to the black
mirror canon
[Music]
okay
no you're not being are being serious oh
my god okay this is happening okay um
just
come on
oh thanks
oh
you look well thanks i'd uh i'd return
the compliment but you just spat food on
my shoe so
it's a revolting shoot oh all about to
kick you with
oh
is that really hard oh i'm so sorry
number four season three nose dive
do you enjoy that euphoric rush of
someone liking commenting on or
retweeting your pictures or commentary
then you might need to do a nosedive
into your own priorities after watching
this episode which enjoys a byline from
michael sher and rashida jones and is
based on a story by creator brooker
bryce dallas howard stars as lacie an
eager to please office dweller who is
desperate to be popular now part of the
reason for this is that social media has
made it so that she can still keep tabs
on her childhood best friend whose life
is full of hashtag goals it's also
because lacie's not alone and this world
seems to monetize hers and others lust
for perfection making these digital
interactions a form of currency things
go awry and let's just say that howard
may not get as many wedding invites as
she used to starring bryce dallas howard
alice eve james norton and directed by
joe wright critics say behind her pink
and perky facade lacy becomes obsessed
with social media status in nosedive an
episode that demonstrates the dangers of
society's need for approval but does so
with a perfect dose of humor
[Music]
and that's one brushed suite
you want a cookie with that
it's on the house sounds awesome
see you tomorrow see you lacey
oh saw your boy in the fire hat just now
so
cute
he's really something
[Music]
so
[Music]
number three season four uss callister
a winner of five emmy awards this
episode should make us wonder how many
of the tv academy's voters secretly hate
their co-workers by day jesse plemons is
robert daly is a mild-mannered
programming ace who co-founded a popular
multiplayer game he also has a habit of
taking his work home with him stealing
the dna of co-workers and employees who
routinely ridicule him or don't realize
they're the objects of his attraction
and uploading digital copies of them to
his own private star trek like universe
make sure you stay to the end to spot
the voice of a surprise guest star
starring jesse plemmons kristen miliate
jimmy simpson and directed by toby
haynes critics say a masterful blend of
science fiction and horror that explores
the consequences of fantasy run amok uss
callister is as topical as it is
terrifying valdec
that can't be my data scan indicates a
heavily armored gorgon dreadnought
vessel id number nine eight six four
three two one thank you to donnie valdak
must have hijacked it from the fermi hub
and tracked our position
to alaska's shield status shields one
hundred percent tom's been packer
captain primary thrusters rear thrusters
crime if that's valdec he'll rip us to
shreds captain we have to surrender
there's no other way let's not lose our
heads lieutenant wilson
[Music]
heavy damage reported deck six through
ten fires in med center and major
rupture of chicago bay alpha we've got
no choice captain do you want me to open
comms with viaduct's craft captain
negative
shielded 54 there's no way out
captain please not now walton
helmsman packer
take us into that asteroid gas cluster
into the cluster
that's suicide sir it is our only chance
number two season one 15 million merits
a sort of hunger games meets
environmental disaster story the show's
second episode highlights one of its
most popular themes are society's
addiction to fame here we have a world
where humans must pedal exercise bikes
in order to both power their
surroundings and earn merits or payments
ways out include inheritance and
participating on a reality competition
show the episode also showcases black
mirror's uncanny ability to cast actors
just as they're on the verge of hitting
the mainstream starring daniel kaluuya
jessica brown finley rupert everett and
directed by euros lynn critics say
combining the worst aspects of reality
shows talent competitions and a hunger
for fame 15 million merits effectively
shows how anything even our humanity
could be readily exploited
[Music]
situations
[Music]
[Music]
huh
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
season three play test
another example of this show's casting
department's ability to grab talent just
when they become a big deal we're
talking to you lodge 49's wyatt russell
this story is a reminder that the
products that you use safely now may not
have started that way in an allegory to
those who are down on their luck and
willing to sign up for drug trials
russell's cooper is a broke american
stranded in london who agrees to be a
guinea pig for a secretive video game
project in exchange for a plane ticket
home let's just say he's not going to
make that flight starring wyatt russell
hannah john common wunmi masaku and
directed by dan trachtenberg critics say
in play tests the psychologically
horrifying world of virtual reality is
nicely counterbalanced by the sheer
likeability of this episode's
protagonist played by the charismatic
wyatt russell
well done
that was it
see i told you i'm good
now don't worry it's not permanent
um
okay
what is this like some kind of like a
memory test or something like that
you'll find out
okay you might feel a slight twinge as
it initializes
oh
okay
um
commencing at 5 38
you ready yes sir
[Music]
season three hated in the nation season
three of black mirror closes out with a
movie that serves as a cautionary
reminder that cyber bullying and death
threats hurt everyone it starts with
various public figures all of whom have
recently provoked the public enough for
the masses to call for their demise
actually do end up dead in bizarre ways
that's when detective chief inspector
karen park and her team are brought in
to investigate but those who called for
their grisly end must suffer their own
consequences when swarms of robotic
insects turn on them so be careful what
you say on the internet kids starring
kelly macdonald fay marseille benedict
wong and directed by james hawes critics
say hated in the nation concludes black
mirror's third season on a strong note
effectively conveying the sometimes
fatal consequences of online hate
through a narrative that is morally
complex and cinematically invigorating
[Music]
ready
[Music]
what's happening
[Music]
season four archangel
this fourth season episode which is
conveniently directed by former child
star jody foster plays on the idea that
pretty much every parent has thought but
never really had the capacity to enact
instead of worrying about what happens
when your child has access to technology
how can parents harness its powers to
protect their offspring rosemary dewitt
stars is mary sambrell an overprotective
single mom who embeds a neutral implant
in her daughter sarah's brain that
allows her to see her whereabouts and
protect her from dangerous images and
while this works fine when sarah's a
child young enough to be scared of the
neighbor's dog what happens when she's a
teenager making the same mistakes that
marie and her friends probably also made
the short answer disaster starring
rosemarie dewitt brenna harding owen
teague and directed by jody foster
critics say though a bit too on the nose
archangel brings balance to black
mirrors typically frenetic episodes with
a calm contemplative and compelling
installment
hi can i help
i'm just looking
ma'am excuse me
are you ryan trebeki
you stay away from my daughter uh i i
don't know what sarah you know exactly
what i'm talking about you stay away
okay uh she is 15 you junkie piece of
[ __ ] you want the cops in on this i
didn't do anything i will show them what
you did okay you stay away from her or i
will show them this okay
you still got that system yes i have it
so whatever she sees i see and i am
watching you okay so you stay away okay
if she calls you you hang up she comes
to see you you tell her to get away you
just stay away from her okay you stay
away
[Music]
and finally number one season one the
national anthem
the first ever episode of black mirror
lives in infamy for two reasons in
particular the first is that its plot a
prime minister has to do the unthinkable
in the name of saving his country's
kidnap princess prepares audiences for
the show's macabre humor as it pokes fun
at privacy political corruptness and our
obsession with technology the second is
that it became a footnote in a real-life
political scandal a few years later
involving then-prime minister david
cameron starring anna wilson jones
donald sumter rory kinnear and directed
by otto bathhurst critics say this
inaugural tale of political machinations
and elite perversions work as a scalding
satire and a nightmare of burgeoning
technology gone awry making it a perfect
sampler for viewers seeking to step
through the looking glass this is a joke
right
haha my coho it's real
she said pig
sex with a pig
they want me to have sex with a pig
live
on television
this afternoon
we're checking with our embedded
operatives compiling a list of suspects
as we speak meanwhile the demand has
been made
and there's not long to formulate our
response
i'm not taking a pic
page one that's not happening
of course
and friends that about does it for us be
sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and for
even more news scores and
recommendations on the latest tv shows
and movies go to rottentomatoes.com
until next time i'm your host naz perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
10s on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you